I wonder in this episode let's [ __ ]
keep going Rowan Ashley from New Zealand
militia Padang is the king of sting it
only one relationship yeah the one
advice today you guys did a good job
Elin here Brendan I actually met you
when you came here and even so early on
in your comedy career man that was so
funny I hope you come back both the oh
you skipped us for some reason yep I'm a
better person I know why Connor took a
stinger for you guys
girls with no arms like I was out in
town and I met this girl and she just
she came on to me and she was gorgeous
man she had a bangin body but she had
she had no arms like it was off at the
at the elbow yeah and I just we get the
best bang couldn't do it but oh my might
seed do it but I just couldn't do it
I just wanna know you guys I've done
Candlestick gives no arms
she's let's gang gang hotspot buzz-buzz
Brunning broke shout it in New Zealand
favorite place I've ever been there in
Dublin top - um no arms listen if it's
like that girl who was that I don't know
how she lost her arms you know I'm
saying because there was that movie
where the girl was riding waves in
Hawaii and a shark took her arms that
[ __ ] turned me on
took her arm mah arms really they went
chops right now what the [ __ ]
cha oh my god yeah this one back then
that [ __ ] was sexy damn bro yeah dude
but no arms if they're a body's a body
dumpers a dumper did ya sure now it is
dude that other people have told you
it's nice here's what I'm saying is dude
what is this lady asking about girls
with no arms you down mmm yeah man look
if people don't have to have arms dude
when you go to heaven nobody has arms so
you might as well practice now and
getting to know people don't bring you
the Dodgers game though a lot of people
get hit with balls yeah a lot of people
catch them the heads up boom you know
I'm saying there's no no Mitford yeah
unless you're trying to wear catcher's
mitt to the baseball game yes so that's
one place you can't take her when there
are billions of places baseball fan they
don't have baseball in New Zealand
he's coming over here he said big
Dodgers fans that's what he said yeah
also dude they're called the Dodgers bro
so if you're not expecting to [ __ ]
eyeball your dude the warnings in the
god didn't mean the Dodgers see it here
by the ball I'll explain my god you're
so right though dude thank you brother
appreciate it hit it man
sometimes just hit it h-town bro you
know what I'm saying yeah you're not as
dumb as they say you are bro dude I'm an
H time well that's right
no this week this week I'll say this to
you man which is guys named Benjamin
Ashley Oh Rowan that's a cool name bro
I'll say this man uh if you got somebody
you don't have arms dude that's great
bro you know and if she don't have any
arms and you have arms then you kind of
you know you already have a chance to be
like kind of like the champion you will
you run the show but also here's the
other thing you can do that cute thing
where you get behind her and kind of do
that kind of thing like she told ya I
love that be fun it'd be so cool man I'd
be fun he could make a baby video for
her family and this she's like guess
what we're having and you're like I
think you're having a school where
you're gonna go to juggling but you're
having and then you go like this baby
love it so I love it man I think if your
mates are just trying to get you to bang
him because she doesn't have arms that's
kind of bizarre I think yeah okay yeah
here's get out more dude if that's if
that's the test of hold up if that's the
hope
here's the other thing without arms
think how much of a piece she is what
that mouth do girl
what them feet do girl I'm sad about it
bro know what do girl she like a
chimpanzee with her feet scrappy
[ __ ] foot she's a you're a limb
changing the control the TV like this
with her foot think about it bro don't
touch me dude after you say that kind of
me bro on your feet you're listening to
you just sexualizing some woman without
arms dude I'm trying to help you imagine
trying to do let's go to cat I mean
Jesus Carole did you stay at a dude with
no arms hmm yeah I feel like I would
[ __ ] like he's gotta I think
compensate for the lack of arms with
either being really nice or really funny
yes and make up for it somewhere else
yeah yeah like all [ __ ] where's my keys
and he's like oh I mean my arms and it's
like a joke yeah and he can't find his
cell arms or keys but something's gonna
something has to give meaning if you
don't have arms his other senses gonna
be super heightened so he might hear
[ __ ]
he might have laser beam dies or you can
just hear people talking two doors down
and [ __ ] you know
yeah or three doors down like that band
I was just got three doors down that's
great
Superman yeah that for me hit that for
me D that's just and then what just hit
it dude what happened to them
I think in New Zealand yeah there's
definitely obviously pastimes hard to
come by sometimes so I guess if you're
out there but it's also when it's a
world of exotic creatures and exotic
types of species also how she lose arms
she born that way yeah if she was trying
to hug a baby in it like a like a sharp
shop or something if she was trying to
hump a tiger shark well then what are we
doing if she is she lost her arms like
kind of huh you know trying to [ __ ]
hug somebody during a sword fight or
something then I would bet on her and
that's the kind of girl that you're
gonna love forever ah dude I remember my
girlfriend bought me the CD in the
Airman's bro and then a day later asked
for the money in pair I'll never forget
that
her name was Stacey she said hey you got
that 1499 Stacey dude is she 50 years
old okay impairments are my frickin
endearment bro
[Music]
happy nothing again god these boys
slapped this is the only one no way
we're good huh this is a dumb they were
good man alright what else we got do
know they had though huh back in the
days a good music man sure we're a Death
Cab for Cutie oh man god I remember him
dude dude and also some I'm an appendage
if you missing an appendage it can be
endearing can be exciting we had a guy
boss he would be this huh bus a guy by
us Oh
got your first name was bus know and he
had wooden legs appendages you know
bottoms and he would spray like animal
attractant on him and he'd sit out there
in the park and all these animals would
come up easy huntin bro beautiful in
many ways some was he would get some of
the annals with a knife yeah broccoli
knee
get your life together I'm not touching